we have previously studied the
translational motion of rigid bodies by
analyzing the motion of their center of
mass we have also studied the rotation
of rigid bodies about a fixed axis this
week we will consider more complicated
examples of rigid body motion where
translation and rotation are both
occurring simultaneously one example is
if I toss a rigid body through the air
but give it a spin at the same time so
that it tumbles in space as it falls a
second example is a wheel that is
rolling along a flat surface its
location is translating but at the same
time it is also spinning about its axis
a natural way to analyze such motions is
to once again take advantage of shawls
theorem which states said one possible
way of describing the general motion of
a rigid body is by a translation of its
center of mass plus a rotation about its
center of mass this separation of the
general case into two distinct types of
motions will greatly simplify our
analysis one of the most common examples
of simultaneous translational and
rotational motion is that of rolling
objects and we will concentrate on this
particular application we will see that
an important detail is whether or not
the object rolls without slipping and
the roll the friction can play in each
case the special case of rolling without
slipping amounts to a constraint
condition that relates the translational
speed of the center of mass to the
radius and the rotational angular
velocity